[Music]
in [ __ ] up none news whoa it's a bit
about JK ku please come to Finland okay
I'll go tomorrow a bad nun is being
accused of helping priests sexually
abuse deaf children one [ __ ] [ __ ]
called it hell I thought it was just
nuns given please [ __ ]
that's what I was thinking person I was
reading it I was hoping it's that mad
that's what I'm saying like if you're if
you're doing something that's so bad to
the point where you're so sexually
repressed to the point where you're
doing like perverse things you guys will
just [ __ ] right because if you're
already going to [ __ ] boys you might as
well just [ __ ] a lady instead and you
won't get to this crazy point you don't
[ __ ] up different people if the scale is
deaf boy boy and then men who knows if
they're even almost sexual whatever yeah
I'm just your actual whatever you're
trying to maybe it is men that's fine
and then there's like there's so many
levels but they just went straight to
like like three arms babies yeah so
might as well just go here instead of
going all the way here
does that make does that make them feel
better like sighs well at least I'm not
sucking women this takes place in
Argentina this nun her name is she was a
Japanese woman whoa her name is a cost
Sokka Kumiko 42 years of luck you Kimiko
Sacco funster Kimiko to you I don't give
a [ __ ] she's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
not a sister what the wasabi [ __ ] keep
going [ __ ] yes no she's she was working
at this school for the hearing impaired
Almer uh you're coming in Argentina or
about eight years from 2004 to 2012 I'm
ignoring that uh so she's she arrived
she arrived in Argentina back in 1977
she became a nun in the year 2000 not
because a big Davis comment what I
imagine was this
this is Houston you're getting here
comments at first I imagined the
Netherlands and she was like oh you're
full tray over here that's what I've
been implanted in my mouth don't [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
David people you're ringing about my
business
god damn it look at this laughs I know I
have a good pass about a logic you can
turn upon two stories will be plenty of
the New Jersey well I saw what he did my
baby fart has zero access
all right so her role was to take care
of these deaf children who lived too far
away so they needed to be boarded at the
school and so she would send children
into rooms to be sexually abused by
priests whoa [ __ ] you apparently also
committed abuse herself to these kids
you wanna force these children to watch
porn on TV there was even this one
instance that was so [ __ ] up reading
it but apparently there was a
five-year-old girl cool who was she
forced to wear a diaper in class because
she liked the day before she had gotten
sexually abused by a priest and so she
will force her to wear a diaper in class
so she could conceal the bleeding oh my
god oh my god this is terrible
yeah it's so [ __ ] up and so that five
year old little girl later when she was
17 years old is when she came forward
okay
damn that sucks it's [ __ ] up good do
this is this priest being murdered right
now oh so so um back in November
police did a raid on the school and been
having for like decade you know
so they did a raid and they arrested
five people they arrested these people
after they found like a lot of evidence
so these on magazines of naked women and
like $34,000 and one of the Reverend
room they are being held in jail right
now and I haven't publicly spoken about
all of this but they're saying that if
they are found guilty they could face 10
to 15 years in prison Burt yeah so that
is not fair I don't think really ders
should be tried by regular law they
should be like hung or some [ __ ] yeah
because there's border leaders yeah I'm
a group I guess you're ordained priests
or nerd on none and your that's how you
say it about Jimmy why you made fun of
hints about what is Australian none No
so if you're an ordained priests or
Australian urn I think you should be
hung or some [ __ ] like that he is
Argentinian yeah so there were a lot of
students that came forward back in 2009
claiming like they've been enduring a
lot of abuse over the years and so the
Vatican started probing like all of this
he started having investigations which
led to the arrest of these people
including this nun
we already cover it up because don't
these kids because they're not they're
not orphans I don't have to go back to
their family if they never said anything
parents never saw anything
wellmaybe was so traumatic they're
scared to reveal it angers me more
because it's [ __ ] nun she's saying
and I never thought I would ever say
this [ __ ] nun so she says that the
allegations are just a strategy of the
victims families to get money from the
church and that there is just a big
campaign to discredit the Catholic
Church in it
I hope she brings in hell and a host of
their scale there's there's like porn
everywhere looks like money everywhere I
don't know I don't know how that works
out in their favor because the kids are
that smart they wanted to implant a
bunch of false evidence all the for no
that's crazy you write the little
five-year-old
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and these priests
are like like one of them is 82 and 65
what are they doing in that school it's
just a school for the hearing impaired
is that why priests and nuns always wear
a bunch of clothes to hide boners and
wet [ __ ] okay you don't want to see a
priest to the bone and walking around to
it they just have a lot of clothes
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] kid touch her dude
and she even molested the kids yeah she
looked so trustworthy dude I know I saw
her I would just give her my social
security number my face is it just
because of the outfit her face I think
it's both just like smiling I just take
care of my kids please yes yes she looks
like me if I was enough of a lightweight
did she looks like she has like very
friendly and homey features yeah we look
like you related
you [ __ ] don't take my face you know
what I think it might be a tough place
for these kids to report a lot of times
the parents that put these kids in there
they're also highly religious which is
why they put them in like a private
school so if your kid comes out and you
know kids are always exaggerating
anyways if your kid comes out and says
hey this person is doing this to me or
whatever a lot of parents do they might
even think like what the [ __ ] why would
you ever say something about them you
must be just trying to come up with an
excuse to not go to this school or
something like that so I think pears
that are really ignorant and there have
this blind faith they might have a hard
time deciphering the truth from their
own like worst fears I agree that's
crazy that's definitely a possibility
there because I even know of like people
that they'll come forward to like their
own parents saying certain things in
this prank like nah
that's impossible yeah it's like what I
mean [ __ ] do you think my five-year-old
mind came up with this crazy scenario
the others saying that they would that
the priest would rape and sexually
abused and fondle students in the
bathroom the dorms garden the basement
at the school and like their own
quarters and pretty [ __ ] up I did have
it to almost every kid by one probably
yeah because I think hundreds since 2009
have come forward that means they do
it's like it's so like normal and
regular to them as I can just wait to
laughs grab a cup of coffee as I was
not going to rate to be like that's
really what it is it's out in the open
yeah it's just so casual like he knows
every day that he wakes up that he's
going to rape somebody want to call
cream yeah they're just like yes today
it's like like I'm just gonna [ __ ] today
I think not
it's like it's against your your biology
and like your human instinct to deprive
yourself of sex because look at what
leads to [ __ ] crazy actually
weird [ __ ] dude they should just give
all priests a bunch of pocket [ __ ]
yeah I just just relax a little fairy
masturbation is you're not supposed to
do that not supposed to that's why
everyone got a little pocket [ __ ]
action but then it's so crazy to me that
big black and white was they're just
religious yeah I'm not gonna have sex
and I'm so holy but yet you're over here
farming all these innocent children
[ __ ] crazy so I could lung is I'm
having sex with these like younger
children does not count as sex in there
I don't know it looked reverse mine
maybe not I don't know I don't know
documentaries on priest boy [ __ ] I'm
pretty sure if we looked it up thank you
cuz Haven but none 209 bad more normal
though yeah I mean that age like that's
more nor priests [ __ ] junkie if it's
priests [ __ ] each other that's more
normal to me yeah yeah cuz if I see a
priest and you know the nun comes by and
her light head carp stuff sloppy she's a
little earlobe he get you know super
fascinating normal get here little bit a
minute now he wants to [ __ ] that ear I
get it yep yeah I'm saying but this like
a little boy or a little girl who's
walking by inside well I can obviously
can't [ __ ] this woman so I gotta get
that baby ass look I understand how that
connection works let you set see your
problem got some sexy-ass uniforms
no yeah I'll tell you that you're low
bro good check you know what hey guys
did you miss us will miss us no more
because you guys can go ahead and
subscribe to our channel and get
notifications of when we post our videos
for more videos click right up here
you
[Music]